negativity from a human is literally
probably the worst thing another human
can do to a human and normally it's your
mom you got your perspective clearly see
that your content was way different just
after I quit my job site like I wanted
to be a youtuber make sense pursue that
[ __ ] it yeah I've ever seen
the punchline is right I mean I have no
idea I saw Caleb in the corner my I
shake his head so obviously this video
is seen a lot and I think I do remember
something in this I guess it doesn't
matter here's the punchline while
everybody's watching - it makes the most
sense in the world to go high risk in
your youth because you can live in your
parents house you - and nineteen people
watching can live in a studio 21 deep
what do you think immigrants do they
live 21 deep and in a [ __ ] studio
like I [ __ ] like know it I lived it I
saw it I watched it like this is exactly
when you guys are supposed to take two
core leaps of faith either go [ __ ] do
it for yourself or get close to
something that you believe in completely
and if you it's more about content like
me cool that makes sense and now alex is
watching like you know this makes sense
for you guys because by the way not I'm
looking at all three of you right now
you might not be entrepreneurs it's hard
it's different it's a talent but cool
then get as close as possible to
something that's awesome rad or fun or
entrepreneurial whether that's a human
skateboarding go and [ __ ] link up go
diem right now or email or or hit up on
YouTube message the 17 coolest
skateboarders that you think and be like
I will work for you for free if you're
privileged in two ways there's two
privileges
there's the privilege of your parents
can help you great that's fine that's
not bad
then just own it don't be like you're
doing it it's about truth or the
privilege of humility the privilege of
loving to eat dirt the privilege that
your mindset is so right that when the
skateboarders like cool come to Malibu
you're like oh [ __ ] okay go on
Craigslist be like yo like and then also
work at Burger King night shift like the
privilege of humility either be the
skateboarder that has a [ __ ] blog or
go work for the skateboarder or next go
and [ __ ] what you do for me what you
three do for me DM on Instagram right
now the coolest skateboard shop or brand
and be like I produce amazing content
for YouTube and Instagram I have a
funny feeling if every [ __ ] kid was
watching this video right now DMS 13
companies or people that they think are
rad with the I make amazing content for
Instagram or YouTube they're gonna find
themselves a very interesting reply
that's my 2018 challenge DM 13 [ __ ]
that you think are awesome or companies
right and tell them that you make
awesome content on Instagram and YouTube
and see what the [ __ ] happens change the
course of people's lives if they have
the privilege of oh by the way there's a
third privilege you have sold a ton of
[ __ ] chach cos on eBay and saved up
ten thousand bucks and you can go to
[ __ ] in Oakland and live for four and a
half months because you earned it
because you went on Craigslist free and
flipping on Facebook it's all here so
[ __ ] proud of you man you know many
people sit in that IT job for their life
[Music]
could you stop hey guys hi nice to meet
you hello thank you ready go you guys
good
it's good everybody how are you great
the biz ops project management thing is
interesting to me do you really mean an
impact here yeah you took a notice they
tried to you got a lot of fans out there
yeah yeah yeah oppressed yeah I try to
you did yeah it's not that easy to do by
the way you made a real impact yes I
know what now I go back to school and
what is he cool UC Irvine you cellphone
yeah how long I have I'm gonna go into
my sophomore year there kid just for 19
yo is it harder now because of this is
such a handy I college environment
actually it's harder to go back I didn't
really pay much attention now just like
ya know it's either force now looks like
you can't even unsee it yeah I know I
know but you can go different route if
you want to like make your parents happy
you can just turn it into a vacation
yeah yeah for real that's one yeah just
don't feel out
make sense yeah like if there's a
Afghani he's coming to an hour away and
giving the talk and you're interested in
that go if Casey doesn't impromptu
pop-up meet-and-greet and you want to go
and you have to miss science miss
science do you understand to the end
okay this is awesome
learning how to make money online can be
tricky which is why I wanted to put out
an article that can be a resource for
anyone and everyone looking to make a
few hundred extra
into a thousand or even ten into a
thousand I'm teaching gonna going to
teach you how to turn zero into a
thousand for what feels like the last
thirty years hundreds
Asaf online the
the worst part is quite neither excuses
with all my heart I've always had to
pander to that response because of the
walk I'm straight I both know I've
always had to have sympathy and empathy
for the first time might be eliminated
the excuse of having no money it's
called the Craigslist resection
medicare's ourselves on
you feeling good about it yeah so sure
it may take you a teashop minutes to
make that extra 20 bucks but trust me
that's a whole lot better than doing
whatever it is that you're doing
otherwise I seriously cannot get this
opportunity out of my make the kant's
make a context there of like you know if
you're complaining yes
you know like for a lot of people that
you don't need a hundred bucks yeah so
you need to hedge there a little bit do
you understand yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that's probably my biggest issue at hand
right with so much to do like where does
this even sit what what does it you know
for example when I see it I'm like what
does that even require of me
[Music]
[ __ ] out
[Music]
they all sound so great in theory
they're just so much energy at work
right so underestimated how much energy
goes in I know you deal with a lot of
entrepreneurs artists tell that I'm a
poet
oh it's bumpy eventually I went from
like sharing bread and stuff here and
there is like an old basement like
making like money from share going to
the bike shows no but mics and like
doing curated show
they're like so often you remind me of
my dad who died like that emigrate has a
story came here with nobody answered my
dad your videos if I was like crying
like he loves you somebody no it's
trying to tell me thank you
like what's your name
yeah yeah yes like we got waiver
together thank you so much thank you
photo who one sec we have field passes
yeah I want to go when do we play
relatively soon not immediately thirty
twenty thirty and six six thirty
probably 20-30 minutes okay yeah we came
all the way from Arkansas because we
love you so much and we think when it so
much thank you
for the content that you put out and it
completely changed both of our lives in
the way they react the way they would
what we do in our business and our jobs
and everyday life just wanted to say
there's so much
[Music]
Contracting your house is a different
house and we're bringing up
that's way for one more time want to
make sure what kind of contract
extraction so are you thinking from a
sales standpoint or from a marketing
style I know you're you're more into
everything you know to me to me that's
why I ask then you notice how I don't
ask that often I think the business
you're in is more predicated on sales
upfront than it is branding great what's
the mean so it's amazing like look I
never think I'm always right and more
importantly I always think that I would
do sales more okay got it okay you
spending one minute on what video or how
you're gonna brand position yourselves
as female leaders is one minute away
from sales that's why I'm giving you
answer I know it's a counter answer to
my normal advice but I believe your
business up front establishing through
sales a foundation it's outrageously
important my point of view in watching a
lot of construction businesses being
built and general contractors thank you
but you know right I know it's like
super counter to what I normally say but
this is why I always want to make Russia
get it I get it but that's why context
matters that's why I wanted to do that's
why I do this
yeah cuz I curveball when I know all the
details
get if you can get a couple if you can
get a nice little business going with a
foundation then you can take the risk of
branding down
I didn't bring vaynermedia first I did
sales understand when you're doing that
kind of business especially in your
sector oh yeah you gotta reverse
engineer your customer your customer
will respond to sales who wants to sneak
one in like Fred negativity from like
friend issues being here eating none
who's cheating on who like whatever like
what if I walk home tonight and my wife
is cheating on me I can deal with that
easy easy
all right easy I'll tell you why I'll
tell you why first thing I would do like
I do everything in my life I would look
at myself
first 100% walking in a man with my wife
and I'd be like there's so much of what
I've done to create this moment I
believe that you may not believe me you
just don't know me
I believe it with all my heart yeah
friend negativity is easy I don't hear
it
like I love my friends but like if
they're negative like I my friends being
negative only leads to me spending less
time with them but I won't cut them out
completely if I grew up with them yeah
if they're my homies but I'll hang out
with them once a year I'll be there for
them but like negativity from a human is
literally probably the worst thing
another human could do to a human and
normally it's your mom you know and so
it's your mom 50% of the time think
about how crazy that is
so that's easy bro only because that's
on me
you can limit your time with your mom
you can limit your time with your best
friend you could tell your girlfriend or
husband to go [ __ ] themselves
[Music]
you could you're accepting to be in that
relationship that's on you
yeah I feel like even when I give it
away and I don't speak to them the
chatter of them talk like that means you
value their opinions yeah
I don't yeah if you're cutting them out
cuz they're negative in theory you don't
value their opinion but you do you're
doing it as a tactic it's not where
you're you're not all the way there yet
that's where you need to look at it yes
it means that you might believe that I
don't get in ladies love knows what to
do
[Music]